my name is Brian Hughes I'm a developer
evangelist at Microsoft and you can find
me everywhere online at net RIA so on
Twitter github stuff like that and so
today we're gonna talk about kind of a
perennial topic in JavaScript we're
gonna talk about how this works in the
context of JavaScript now we're going to
talk about something I haven't seen as
much discussion on recently and that's
how that this works with a lot of the
new features that have come into the
language over the last couple years
because they actually kind of change how
this works a little bit of a first we'll
talk about the basics of how this works
this may be review for some of you but
it's really important that we understand
some of the foundational basics of how
this works in JavaScript and so for this
section everything we're gonna see is
actually gonna be es5 code so it will
have worked in browsers going back to I
was it like 2009 2010 something like
that so first up we have a very simple
function it doesn't really do much it's
just a function kind of sitting there
and it's what's called a function
declaration so we have this function we
call this function and we check to see
what this equals we're comparing it to
global Global's of something specific to
no js' if you're in the browser then
this equivalent would be window but same
basic thing and we see that we call this
basic function and we see that this
pointer is equal to global so all right
that's kind of our first little data
point in this but let's make this a
little bit more complicated so now we
have an object we create this object
here science-u variable come my object
and then we have a function called my
function so we call my object that might
function and we check to see what this
pointer is inside of this function and
now we see that this pointer is set to
my object by the way I suppose I tend to
call it this pointer a lot because I
come from a C++ background it's not
exactly accurate in JavaScript but he go
what I mean oh yeah so we see that this
in this case equals my object it's no
longer global but we kind of expect that
to be the case you know this is meant to
refer to the calling context of a
function which is usually the object
that that function is associated with
and like this is this code would work in
in
other object-oriented language at least
that supports the syntax so if you're in
C++ or Java c-sharp something like that
you have an object and you have a method
as part of that object and you call that
method at this point
well this in C++ Java and c-sharp will
also equal my object so this is kind of
like what we expect this is sort of the
default assumption of how this works in
JavaScript because this is how it works
in every language we start to change
things up a little bit in JavaScript and
all of a sudden the way JavaScript works
deviates pretty strongly from other
languages so let's say we do this the
object declaration is exactly the same
as we have before but instead of calling
that method directly where instead gonna
assign it to a variable first we're
gonna go my function equals my object
about my function so it's the exact same
function you know we haven't really
changed that object at all we didn't
like remove that we didn't like delete
my function from my object it's still
sitting there but now it's on a variable
and so we'll call that variable directly
and all of a sudden this no longer
equals my object is actually changed and
it turns out in this case that this is
back to equaling global like we had in
that very first example and so like this
is pretty confusing this tends to trip
up a lot of people because it feels like
this changes on us it's like something
changed this like wow our code was
running what turns out it nothing
actually changed it has to do with how
JavaScript creates that this value where
it comes from it's actually a pretty
straightforward rule but it's really
counterintuitive so the way this works
in JavaScript is if it is called in this
form object dot function or if you did
like object you know square bracket
string function either way it's the same
but if we have an object reference
followed by a function in the code like
it sits there in the text of your code
then it's going to take whatever this
value is sitting in front of it it
doesn't matter what it is but it'll take
that value and we'll set this equal to
that value but if it's not called like
this if there's not a dot and not a
square bracket right there in front of
our function it's going to assign this
to global it's just kind of like a
default this value is always going to be
global or once again
if we're in the browser like this is how
this works in all of JavaScript it's
actually just this rule right here so
it's it's one of those things that
almost can seem a little overly simple
and it's different from how every other
language works so it tends to cause a
lot of confusion but this is the rule
like if you remember this rule
everything else comes from that and we
see this if we look at a little bit more
complex example like this so we have my
object again we have my function just
like we did before and we're gonna do
this console log but then we're gonna
have this little set timeout right here
this could be any asynchronous method
you know it could be a file system
reader a database call or anything like
that anything where we have a call back
and so we're gonna call my object that
my function just like we did before and
so this console once again this is
exactly like we had before this equals
my object but then in here we see that
it actually gets flipped around so on
this line line 3 this equals my object
and on on line 5 this no longer equals
my object it equals global instead it's
like this is something that shows people
oh because it's like oh this is one
thing here and then it says totally
different thing here even though that's
the same block of code
the reason is going back to that rule on
this page or on the slide right here so
if we follow these rules okay this first
function is called right here so we had
that reference and we see that my object
is being referenced from my function as
being a reference from my object so
we're gonna set this in this function
call equal to my object but there's no
such object reference right here so set
timeout I mean this is little indirect
but inside if we kind of peeked inside
the VM it's essentially as if they were
calling that function directly so there
it's just a function called there is no
dot reference in front of that function
when set timeout calls it and so it
follows back to that sort of default
rule and we'll assign this equal to
global so we're just following those
same basic rules and but we see how we
kind of get this different behavior so
we kind of have to be mindful whenever
we're writing our code there's a couple
other subtleties in JavaScript that you
know slightly off-topic perhaps but I
think it's really important and this is
the difference in what we call function
expressions versus function declarations
these are the formal names for them
they're you know in the spec we can
declare functions in two ways and es5
specifically we can go function some
main parentheses and then curly braces
or we can go VAR my function expression
equals function over here and so they
look like they do the same thing and
most people tend to use them
interchangeably and they are very very
similar but they're they look different
though of course in this one there's no
VAR there's no equal sign and they're
called this it's kind of a language
theory type of thing but they're called
this because this cannot sit inside of
something else right this is kind of its
own statement we can think of it as
having a semicolon at the end javascript
we don't have to but we can kind of
think of it like that this is sort of
equivalent to like an if statement you
know like you can't go VAR my var equals
if right you know that's just not
allowed same thing with a function
declaration but we had this other rule
that looks pretty much identical but
actually follows a different part of the
spec if you dig into it and that's a
function expression and that's where
this can be a value and this can exist
inside of some kind of assignment with
some kind of expression like you could
even if you wanted to for some reason
you could do function parentheses you
know curly braces plus one like you
could actually do math on that there's
not really reason to you're just gonna
get not a number but you know
hypothetically you can do that according
to the spec so they look a little
different but then let's also take a
look at there is a bit of a behavior
difference so let's take a look at that
so if we have a function declaration
let's say we define our function here
then we call it above we call it a for
we've declared the function not after
this works completely fine and that
happens in JavaScript because of a thing
called hoisting which you may have seen
before and JavaScript the wave variables
work whenever you go VAR you know my
variable equals some other thing well
the engine actually kind of splits that
into two pieces it's gonna take that var
name thing and it moves it to the very
top of your function or your file under
the hood like it's like it exists up
here kind of at the very top but then
the assignment part still happens below
with a normal variable now this also
happen
with function declarations but since
there's no assignment it basically just
moves this entire thing up to the very
top okay under the hood kind of inside
the engine and so this works just fine
but it breaks if we use a function
expression because what this is gonna do
here like I said you know we take that
first part the VAR name and we hoist
that to the top so I basically have VAR
my function semicolon up here and then
down here we end up it's like it gets
rid of this bar and just has my function
equals function it's kind of what's
going on under the hood so we think
about this from the intents place back
perspective we say VAR my function
without anything which implies that it's
set equal to undefined right here like
that variable doesn't actually get this
value the function until it gets down
here after he tried to call it so we get
an exception so this is another thing to
be careful that can kind of trip people
up this is why I actually recommend
always these function declarations never
use function expressions unless you have
to because this can this is just kind of
easy to get tripped up by I even get
tripped up whenever I actually do this
sometimes now of course things get even
a little more complicated with function
expressions we actually can have what's
called a named function expression and
we can actually we can this is totally
valid JavaScript we can go VAR my
function equals function my other
function like notice these names are not
the same but we can totally do that this
actually works but there's some weird
things with where these names are
available so this variable is once again
is you know hoisted so it's kind of like
it exists up here at the top so that's
available to the entire file but this
name right here is only available inside
of this function it's not available
outside of it so if we try to call my
function down here that works fine
because we have the same here but if we
were trying to call this name we
actually get a reference here it says
sorry I don't know what this variable is
I haven't seen it but then inside of it
we can actually call both and by the way
all of this code I actually ran that's
why I have a little bit of logic here
because I always get an infinite loop so
just another little thing to be aware of
but like this is the basics of functions
in JavaScript and everything is built on
top of this now I mentioned earlier that
you know we have this this value and it
wasn't exactly what we wanted this
with an asynchronous call so how do we
get that this set to what we want
well JavaScript has three things or
three methods we can use to actually
manually change the dis value of a
function those are call apply and bind
so with call this allows us to do
something like this we create you know
this object with our function just like
we did before a couple of comparisons in
here it's got a couple of arguments and
then over here we create just some other
random object we just want to have an
object hanging around and so we go my
object dot my function dot call it's
like we're accessing a property on this
function that is itself a function and
the first very parameter that it takes
is actually what we wanted this value to
be so we could just manually set it to
anything we want and when we set it to
my other object and we do this
comparison we can actually see that this
with this comparison it does indeed
equal my object and then all the
parameters that come after this are then
passed as a normal primer so we can see
the second parameter here gets assigned
to this first one up here it's kind of
like it internally just slices this off
after it's applied it that is also apply
which is almost identical to call it
looks really really similar the only
difference is that instead of having
each successive parameter being map sort
of one to one up here we supply an array
in this array gets mapped to those
parameters right there
like I said it's almost exactly the same
just a slightly different syntax but
this does in able some really useful
tricks we can do specifically if we want
to like pass values through if you want
to have some function that sort of sits
in the middle of another function you
know say this is debugging or something
we can actually go my function apply
this comma arguments we can take that
arguments keyword and JavaScript let me
just drop it right in here and that way
we can kind of like chain along our
arguments without having to actually
inspect them and see what they are so
that's kind of cool and then finally we
have bind and so bind works a lot like
call except it breaks it into two
separate steps so once again we have the
same object like we had before my other
object and here we say my object my
function bind
and what this does is it's going to
return a new function that has the this
value kind of pre applied to it is how
we can think of it and so we can assign
that to a variable and then we call that
like a normal function so this call
right here where we call this it looks
just like we didn't even do this except
we have changed what this pointer is and
so the bind is what we typically use if
we need to kind of sort of force this
point out of something that we're gonna
pass is say a callback or something like
that it's like that's the basics of how
this works in JavaScript
starting with es5 and is almost exactly
how it worked in even older versions of
javascript - there's just a little weird
edge cases before but so now we're
passed ds5 we've gotten a lot of new
features and there's a couple of key
additions that kind of have some
implications for how this works the
first one is object shorthand notation
so now we can create an object that
looks like this so first of all you
notice i've switched to using constant
instead of art and another new addition
to es 2015 we have my object equals this
and so we have my function like before
myself having to do my function colon
space the word function and then
parentheses we get to get rid of that
colon in that function I'm just kind of
shorten it up cleaning it up a little
bit but I like this I think this is more
readable myself it's just like let's
stuff to kind of have to croc and so
then we can call my object op my
function and we can see that this is
equal to my object just like before then
we do this aliasing and we see that this
value changes so this looks just it
looks exactly and behaves exactly like
when we did my function call it our
colon the word function in parentheses
it's just shorter and indeed this is
syntactic sugar over the old way of
doing it under the hood in the engine it
acts exactly the old way it's going
through the exact same code path but
there is something else new that we got
and that is arrow functions so arrow
functions are one of my favorite
features in es2015 because it really
changes how we kind of write our code
and so it looks like this and I wrote
this kind of like a function expression
um
arrow functions only exist in in
function expressions there's no like
function declaration equivalent a
function we can take you know constant
my function equals and we have
parentheses then we have this equal sign
and this little greater than sign right
here and then we have our function body
right after it so it's shorter it's your
characters we don't have to type out you
know fu NC tion so it's your characters
shorter which is nice and yeah that's
kind of the behavior we have here like
if we look at this code it's behaving
exactly like that first slide we saw so
you know we call this function there's
no objects or anything like going on and
this indeed equals global the thing we
go is the more complicated case so we
have our object inside of it you can see
we have this object or yeah object
shorthand notation like we saw a couple
slides ago we have a set timer but this
time we had the arrow function instead
of a function expression so we call my
object my function this is set to my
objects you know just like before so
once again nothing has changed here but
then inside this set time we notice that
this now equals my object instead of
global this is reversed from what we saw
before and so before I explain that I
have one last a little bit of code that
I actually didn't know before I started
writing the suck it actually surprised
me a little bit but I think is really
cool so we create random object up here
we have our fat arrow function we're
gonna do my function call my object
you know first we just call it and we
say we see that this is not equal my
object we expect that but then we do my
function call and we explicitly tell it
what this value we want but it ignores
it this is still not equal to my object
even when we do call and it turns out
that call apply and bind have no effect
on arrow functions they're basically
ignored and that's because under the
hood what's kind of going on is if you
look at the spec for a normal function
there's like a whole section dedicated
to how you figure out what this is and
there's like all sorts of like
conditionals and stuff like that it's
like it's a little complicated actually
from a specification perspective but if
you look at the fat arrow spec it's it
just skips all that it doesn't have any
of that stuff there there's no logic to
actual or no
ger them to really determine this it
simply takes whatever is outside that
function and applies it internally so in
this case you know this external this is
going to be global because that's just
what this isn't a file so it's gonna
apply it on the inside too and we have
the same thing here it takes whatever
this value is right when we created it
so it's gonna be kinda like right in
this part of the code and just applies
that internally so this way we get this
sort of like chained this value going to
wrap so now we get to skip doing call
apply and bind because this kind of does
it for us but does it in a stronger way
it means that libraries under the hood
can't mess with that this value and some
libraries do that all right so let's
talk react a little bit I know this is
the no conference but I have a reason
for talking about react because it
illustrates another issue that we still
kind of have with this and where gets
complicated so we have code that looks
like this we have a component that
extends the sort of react based
component class this is how we create
all components we have a little click
Handler we're gonna call this handler
whenever someone clicks on this button
right here and specifically because we
wire that up right here we give it this
little on click property to our button
and we say on click equals this dot on
click so we added this reference right
here however under the hood and react
what happens is you know this sort of
falls away it just gets a function
expression this is actually just like
when we did variable a listing earlier
so when react calls on click this is all
wrong it's actually it's set to global
or well window in this case because it's
a browser and we can log and we see that
this is not my component in this matters
because in a react component there are
two key properties on the object what is
called props in the other called state
and we have to work with those just to
figure out stuff about the component and
how we want to respond to this click
event so we have to have the correct
this right here but this doesn't work so
we have to change that well one way we
can do that is to use a fat arrow
function arrow functions they were
originally called fat arrow functions
for reasons so you might Kimmie chop
that in occasionally so we have an arrow
function here that then calls this dog
and this works this actually sets to
this pointer we want correctly because
this this arrow function right here
takes to this value from just outside of
it
which is set correctly now this is not
ideal and react if you've heard about
reacting out it's a UI framework for the
web and it's known for being really
performant and the way it does this is
with what's called a virtual Dom it has
this in-memory representation of what
the entire UI state is and whenever it's
time to rerender it actually recreates
that entire tree from scratch every
single time because it's a memory that's
really fast but then it has to
synchronize those changes to the actual
Dom itself which is slow the naive way
would be just copy everything over but
it doesn't do that it looks to see what
has changed and only copies over the
bits that have changed now whenever we
come into this render function you know
we're creating a new function each time
so since we're creating a new function
reactions can look at this and be like
oh the property changed and it's gonna
think it always changed even if it
didn't so this is actually a performance
gotcha
and not a good practicing yet so instead
they recommend doing this we have a
constructor for a component that gets
called whenever this thing is first
created and we call a super constructor
and then we do this stunt on click
equals this stud on clicked bind this so
we're back to using bind so that we can
set this value to what we want and then
whenever react calls does we're back to
using this we don't have that thought
that arrow function anymore we get the
correct this pointer and we also get the
performant nature that react really
wants so this is how react recommends we
do it right now and it works kind of a
boilerplate II a little bit verbose so
not really ideal and we have to kind of
remember to do this and it's can be kind
of subtle until you've worked with it
for a little while and know that we have
to do that so this is where we start
looking ahead to the future there's a
new proposal out there that's really
going to change this and that's called
instance properties or well it's kind of
built on this so in 20s 2017 sorry this
is how we do it right now if you want to
have a property on a class something
that's not a function we have to assign
it in the constructor we'd say this not
my property equals 10 right
and we do that inside of the constructor
and then we get a nice little property
we can log it and it sort of works so we
would expect but this is kind of a
runtime sort of thing you know this is
we're writing code to do it we can have
it's complex expression as we want but
you know this is it makes a little
difficult for tooling and various other
things like that in addition to being
verbose like if we have some tooling
that's trying to figure out that helps
you with say refactoring a side of your
IDE it can be feat difficult to figure
out what your properties actually are
because they can be interspersed in all
kinds of complex coding be hard to
figure out so there's a new thing out
there called class field declarations
that's coming out this is at stage 3 of
the TC process of the tc39 process of
getting something in so whenever someone
wants to add something to the language
you know they submit some proposals and
it goes to this process it started
talking to save 0 which is like
basically like I have a rough idea I
don't know what it looks like and then
it gets refined over time it goes
through saves 0 to 1 to 2 to 3 and then
to 4 and these just have to do with like
how we get something into the official
spec and into browsers so this is pretty
far along it's not done but it's really
close and unlikely to change and so what
we can do now is inside our class we can
say my property equals 10 you know we
don't have to have it inside the
constructor anymore it just sits there
and we can do a new instance we can log
it and it works so this is pretty
nice-looking we like this now this has
some special implications though
especially around functions because now
we could actually do this we can create
a property and we can give it an arrow
function and at this point our course
works differently for arrow functions
that have so we've been talking about
and that is still true here mning a
little bit special though that's really
nice so when we have an arrow function
that's assigned to a class field
property then this value this
automatically gets pulled from that
class instance it does at every single
time and it's something that can't be
changed by call apply and bind and so
with this you know we can see that with
this code here we actually alias this
function to a variable and call it and
we see we still get even with this a
listing we still get the this value that
we want so that's like really cool and
we finally have methods for classes and
then this way that works in JavaScript
the way it works in Java C sharp and C++
I think this is nice because it's really
consistent we don't have to think
through like Oh what are the rules again
exactly which rule is taking precedence
over which one it just works and it
always works the same way and so if we
act specifically we can rewrite that
class to now look like this so we have
in our on click method again but we do
it as a classical property with an arrow
function and we're back to the code that
we had on that very first react
slide except instead of being object
shorthand notation it's an arrow
function and so we have onclick equals
this sivan click but because this is
already bound we don't have to in the
constructor do that you know this
doesn't click equals this at all clicked
up buying this like we get to leave it
out entirely and we get something that I
honestly think it's more readable too
there's just like this left less
boilerplate and corrupt and we can focus
more on the exact problem and so it's
really cool to see like how the language
has been evolving and JavaScript is very
much an evolving language must being in
they do a test every day at noon if
you're wondering what that is
so yeah javascript is an evolving
language and it's like we're getting all
these little niceties that for the most
part kind of papering over the rough
edges of the language and they make it a
little easier to use without getting cut
by some weird like errata you know edge
case in the spec and we're gonna keep
getting even better after that so it's
really exciting to see where we're gonna
get but that oh I thank you all for
listening
[Applause]